there are no bad gpus let me just say
that right from the get-go there's only
bad pricing and bad positioning so if
you were heavily anticipating the launch
of the RTX 50 Series from Nvidia and the
RTX 55090 at $2,000 seemed a bit Rich
for your blood you might have had your
site set on the relatively less
expensive $1,000 RTX 580 but if you've
been watching the launch reviews that
came out today you might be thinking
whoo hold on a second why do all these
reviewers think this GPU sucks this
video is meant to explain the reasoning
as simply as possible the RTX 580 does
not suck as a GPU it sucks in terms of
pricing it sucks in terms of positioning
it sucks in terms of the value at offers
especially if you compare it to previous
generations but most importantly I think
it sucks because it represents how
Nvidia is treating PC gamers in 2025
especially considering how well they've
been doing in recent
years excellent today's video is brought
to you by the Paul's Hardware store on
Pauls hardware. net the only official
source for Hardware merchandise
tantalizing t-shirts brilliant beer sets
high quality hoodies and more all
featuring The Classic thumb screw for
tasteful and refined viewers or the 8
bit thumb screw for tasteful and refined
viewers who hate curves new designs are
added sporadically and at random so head
over to Pauls hardware. net and get some
of that sweet sweet merch right now or
not right now after you watch the video
either way so I want to point out that
this is not a review video I'm doing
things a little bit differently this
time around for the RTX 50 Series launch
but let's start out with some context if
you watch my YouTube channel there's a
reasonable chance that you enjoy
building computers and there's lots of
reasons to build your own computer I
like to do it because it's fun but also
because of upgrades you can build the
system now you can upgrade it in the
future so PC Builders are always on the
lookout for what's coming next because
often historically when something comes
out that's new we get a boost in
performance and often we get parts that
come out that cost less money they give
more performance and I often compare
that to when I used to play World of
Warcraft when a new expansion would come
out your current armor set no matter how
much time you had spent Gathering it and
putting it together to be the best in
slot in every single category when the
next expansion comes out chances are the
entry level items there are going to
outperform your epic gear and it's often
been a similar case when new generations
of gpus launch the mid-tier offerings
from the next gen will typically
outperform even the best GPU that was
available from the previous generation
now I'm not intending this video to be
too focused on Mo's law because there's
certainly discussion to be had there but
whether the advancements came from
manufactur in process improvements or
GPU microarchitecture advancements each
generation there's more performance and
the performance Improvement is usually
split up a little bit you get a little
bit more value on the GPU side so those
prices would typically go up a little
bit each generation but you also get a
big boost in sort of free performance
for the consumer that you got just by
waiting for the Next Generation to
launch but I'm talking about historical
context here and that's what's very
important for this video if you go back
10 plus years or so ago to the GTX 700
series this was an Nvidia first launched
Titan class gpus and this was in my
opinion when Nvidia started a long-term
strategy first off using price anchoring
with those Halo tier cards to gradually
increase the perceived value of their
cards but also treating that gen on-
genen performance increase a little bit
differently if you're offering more
performance you're offering more value
so why should Nvidia be giving consumers
free performance with just a
generational upgrade when instead they
should just be charging consumers
proportionally for that increased
performance and was first heavily
represented with the RTX 20 series
launch and the way Nvidia stacked the
pricing of those cards on top of the
existing cards that were already out
rather than replacing them with higher
performing models but instead of just
talking about this why don't I show you
with some actual performance numbers
taking a trip back in time to September
2014 when the GTX 980 launched and the
performance data here is sourced from
the tech PowerUp database other than the
launch date and the MSRP which is $550
for the 980 we have comparisons to the
card that's two generations old in the
ad80 class the last gen card in the 80
class and the last generation Flagship
the 80 class card two generations before
the 980 was actually the 680 cuz they
skipped the 800 series The 680 was
actually a pretty beastly card but the
980 was still 71% faster and compared to
the last gen 780 it was 38% faster and
versus the 780 Ti the previous
generation Flagship it was 11% faster in
the Next Generation the 80 class carb
was a GTX 1080 which sold for $600 MSRP
and launched in May 2016 versus the two
jens's old 7 80 the 1080 was a 109%
performance boost versus the last gen
980 it was 51% faster and even versus
the previous generation Flagship 980 TI
it was a 31% performance increase so
here you can see that anyone who
invested in the 10 series The 1080 in
particular was getting a pretty decent
performance bump and it was only $50
more expensive a couple years later in
September 2018 the RTX 2080 launched
this was the Advent of the r series rate
tracing cards and also Nvidia increased
the MSRP to 700
from $600 much to the shagrin of many
reviewers so some value was lost due to
that price increase but we still had a
pretty decent performance bump compared
to the GTX 980 the 2080 was 110% faster
compared to the GTX 1080 it was 39%
faster and even compared to the
venerable GTX 1080 TI it was 9% faster a
couple years after that in September
2020 we had the debut of the RTX 380
which also sold for $700 or at least it
was supposed to if you guys remember uh
the RTX 380 was actually a great deal
for $700 but it rarely sold for that
much but this was also heavily
influenced by cryptocurrency mining
still compared to the two generations
old GTX 1080 we had a 126% performance
Improvement compared to the RTX 2080 we
were 63% faster and compared to the 2080
TI 36% performance gen on gen versus the
last gen Flagship and that is good
that's a good representation of a gen
on- genen performance uplift for a ad0
class card versus last gen Flagship and
despite the 20 series only coming in at
9% this was what had been the standard
for quite some time prior to that now my
next line here I'm adding two cards the
RTX 480 and the 480 super even though
they were separated by a year and a half
or so from September 2022 to January
2024 the 4080 super in my opinion is
what the 4080 should have been and that
is the card that we should be comparing
the 5082 or the 5092 for that matter
that said I listed them both here so we
can compare both the 4080 came out for
1,200 bucks the 4080 super was a price
reduction down to $1,000 despite being a
little bit faster so versus the 2080
they were about 143 and 147% faster
versus the RTX 380 they were about 50%
faster and versus the last gen Flagship
390 TI about 12 and 14% improved so
looking at this chart through 2024 we
can see a lot of green uh we can see
typically over 100% performance increase
versus the two jens's old card healthy
double digit performance increase versus
last generation and even versus the last
gen Flagship we're always in the green
sometimes 10% sometimes 30% or more so
now let's add the RTX 580 eek I'm using
supplemental data here from Hardware
unboxed the 4K cumulative benchmarks and
we only have a 65% Improvement for the
580 versus the 3080 less than half of
what we've typically gotten in previous
generations only an 11% performance
increase versus the 480 super and that
is being generous if you check out some
other reviews and I've listed multiple
ones in the description down below it
sometimes is less than 10% and versus
the RTX 490 we're in the red we're at
negative 177% and if you're looking at
that and saying well last G Flagship
4090 was sort of a a unicorn and it
stood on its own and it was that much
more expensive because of the increased
performance that is part of nvidia's
strategy they want to make the Halo tier
card look really good in terms of
performance but also be super expensive
to establish that luxury brand pricing
and then for anyone who doesn't want to
cough up two grand or more well your
step down from that is going to be a
very disappointing experience if you're
looking at the historical context
speaking of which I have one more graph
to show you here just showing the
progress over time where we can see
pricing has continued to go up while
relative performance has continued to go
down which means anyone who doesn't want
to pay that premium tier pricing is
going to be punished because of it now
in particular if you look towards the
end of this chart just in the past say 3
four 5 years you can see what a price
increase Nvidia has tacked on to the RTX
80 class card and I would compare that
to how Nvidia has been doing in that
same period of time their value as a
company has skyrocketed they're doing
quite well and I know businesses are
going to business and that's just how
the world works and we have to deal with
it but it's frustrating knowing that
Nvidia started as a company for PC
gaming making graphics cards to play
video games with and they've come a long
way they wouldn't have come this far
without PC Gamers buying their products
and supporting them AI is a whole other
animal and they're doing great over
there they've had much success but it
really sucks when it comes to their
GeForce lineup and the cards that they
still make for gamers it seems like
they're trying to extract the maximum
amount of profit from PC Gamers while
providing the minimum viable product and
that after so long is just disappointing
thank you guys so much for watching this
video if you want some links to some FL
reviews check those in the video
description down below and also if you'd
like to help support my channel you can
check out my store at Pauls hardware.
net where Shirts Mugs pint glasses and
all manner of high quality merchandise
thank you so much for watching once
again and we'll see you all in the next
video